كيف تفهم هذا الحديث الاسرائيلي المتوالي
عن استعداد اسرائيل ومبادرتها باقتراح
صفقه لتبادل الرهائن ووقف مؤقت لاطلاق
النار تحياتي لك والساده المشاهدين يعني
اعتقد ان لعبه عض الاصابع بدات فيما يتصل
بهذه المرحله من تبادل الاسرى اسرائيل
اعتادت على التسريبات الاعلاميه لجس النبض
وايضا اعتادت على تقديم المقترحات من اجل
الراي العام ايه الداخلي نلاحظ ان هنالك
انقسام في الداخل في اسرائيل هنالك ضغط
باتجاه تحقيق هذه الصفقه ك كانجا وهنالك
حاجه عند القياده السياسيه ونتنياهو
تحديدا لاثبات انه يسعى باتجاه هذه الصفقه
ولكن كل ما يحدث على الطاوله كل ما يحدث
على الارض هو يشير الى انه اسرائيل تحاول
ان تضغط لتخفيض الثمن الذي ستدفع بهذه
الصفقه بالمقابل حركه حماس تحدثت بوضوح مع
سقوط وانتهاء ال التبادل السابق بانها لن
تعود الى ذات الشكل هي تريد وقف دائم
للاطلاق النار واعتقد ان وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار يعني هزيمه بالنسبه لاسرائيل في ظل
كل التفاعلات والتعقيدات في المشهد
السياسي وفي ظل حاجه جيش الاحتلال لتقديم
شكل الانجاز واستعاده الثقه بعلاقته مع
مجتمعه هذا كله يجعل من لعبه عض الاصابع
صعبه نشاهد اليوم ان هنالك تصعيد ايه
ميداني دوما مع اقتراب الحديث او مع تصاعد
الحديث عن الصفقه يحدث تصعيد ميداني يحدث
محاولات ايضا لتوسيع المساحات التي تتواجد
فيها قوات الاحتلال لاحظنا انها تتحدث عن
انسحابات بضمن الصفقه واعاده انتشار
وبالتالي تحاول ان تضغط بهذا الاتجاه ايضا
الورقه المؤلمه الورقه الانسانيه واستخدام
ايه الغذاء
وا الماء وال الطبابه كاسل الحه هي تعزز
من كل هذه الادوات وبالتالي هي لا تريد ان
تذهب الى التزام يوقف الحرب بالنسبه لها
ولكنها تقبل بعمل مرحلي ربما تعيد ترتيب
اوراقها من خلاله بالمقابل الجانب
الفلسطيني هو يعرف هذه المحددات يعرف ان
اذا كان كلمه وقف الحرب صعب بتقبلها
اسرائيليا هل تغيير الترتيبات هل حرب اقل
سخونه او اكثر بروده تبريد الحرب هو امر
مقبول اسرائيليا لانه ايضا ربما يكون
مقبولا
امريكيا يعني المرحله ال الجديده التي
تحدثت عنها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والتي تتحدث عنها اسرائيل ايضا والتي قد
تكون مقبوله اسرائيليا هي مرحله تتضمن
الحصار تتضمن ايه السماء المفتوحه
والعمليات المفتوحه وبالتالي هي حاله اللا
امن في قطاع غزه والعمليات وحاله ال اللا
يقين وبالتالي هذه حاله حرب مفتوحه
ومستمره وتستنزف في ظل الواقع الماساوي
الذي يعيشه قطاع غزه اليوم نتحدث عن ازاحه
سكانيه هائله باتجاه الجنوب نتحدث عن واقع
انساني لا يمكن تصوره احتياجات انسانيه لا
يمكن تخيلها اسرائيل ومن خلفها الولايات
المتحده ترفض تقديم اي التزام يتصل حتى
بالمساعدات الانسانيه وهذا ما يبرر كل هذا
التسويف في القرار في مجلس الامن باتجاه
اما تمييعه او استخدامه ضمن الصفقه ربما
تذهب الولايات المتحده لعقد ترتيبات ضمن
هذه الصفقه بقرار مجلس الامن لرفع الحرج
عن اسرائيل ولو جزئيا ولكن بترتيبات تضمن
لاسرائيل العوده الى عملياتها باللحظه
التي تتوقف
فيها الاتفاقيه المتصله بتبادل
الاسرى هل بدات اعاده الحسابات في مساله
الحرب نفسها بعد 75 يوما بالنظر الى كل ما
حدث طبعا ل ربما لا يكون في حسابات
الاسرائيليين عدد القتلى المدنيين في غزه
ولكن اكيد في حساباتهم الثلاثه اسرى الذين
قتلوا عدم النجاح في تحرير اي اسير بعمليه
عسكريه حتى هذه اللحظه
عدم وق في الصواريخ عدم وقف المقاومه في
استهداف المدرعات والاليات الاسرائيليه
والجنود الاسرائيليين 12 جنديا في في 24
ساعه
ا ما الذي تغير في الحسابات بعد 75
يوما اولا النقطه الفارقه كانت الثلاث
اسرى الذين قتلوا كانت نقطه فار فارقه با
اصطفافات الشارع الاسرائيلي حول اهالي
الاسرى العديد من اهالي القتلى ايضا ايه
ايه اصطفوا الى جانبهم في الشارع الاصوات
اصبحت اكثر يعني صراحه وجراه فيما يتصل
بالمطالبه باعطاء الاولويه لاعاده الاسرى
وبان هذه الحرب ستكون على حساب حياتهم
وبالتالي الشارع يتحدث بهذا الاتجاه
الضغوطات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه بالامس
كان هنالك رفض على سبيل المثال من قبل
رؤساء الجامعات ب تمديد افتتاح العام
الدراسي يريدون العوده الى الحياه
الطبيعيه ايه و هذا غير ممكن في ظل كل هذه
الظروف ضغوط اقتصاديه ضغوط اجتماعيه لا
يوجد افق يوجد حاله من عدم اليقين بالتالي
هنالك حاله من الضغط ربما يكون بطيء ربما
ولكنه زاحف يعني يتدحرج ويتاثر بكل معطيات
الميدانيه المفاجئه حادثه قتل الاسرى كانت
مفاجئه واحدثت رده فعل كبيره ولكن ايه
حوادث مشابهه
ايه اعلانات من قبل ربما المقاومه تصريحات
للاسرى ايضا تؤثر على الراي العام ايضا
الانشقاقات او الانقسامات دعنا نتحدث
الانقسامات في الراي بدات او يعني تظهر
بشكل اوضح واكثر جلاء سواء على مستوى
سياسي او على مستوى عسكري وبالتالي كل هذه
الظروف تشير الى تفاعلات ولكن حتى اللحظه
لم تصل الى نقطه حسم هي ضابطه وهذا ما
يشير الى الذهاب الى الحديث وتسخين الحديث
عن الصفقه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حتى
اللحظه ايضا هي تمارس ما زالت الناعم على
اسرائيل بهذا الاتجاه ربما هي تمنح
اسرائيل مده من الوقت غير معلنه ولكن حتى
اللحظه وفق كل المعطيات الضغط الامريكي
ليس هو الضغط المؤثر الذي يمكن ان يغير
الموازين بهذا الاتجاه